[Musique]
dis-moi pourquoi dis-tu à un peintre
parce que j'aime peindre je dois peindre
j'ai toujours été le peintre que je connais
ce peintre d'os oui
comment tu sais
[Musique]
parce que je ne peux rien faire d'autre alors
crois-moi j'ai essayé
je me considère comme un exilé
tu es Vincent oui frère vendeur je suis
Paul Gauguin nous devons commencer une
révolution comprenez-vous nous devons
créer une nouvelle vision une nouvelle façon de
peindre j'ai passé toute ma vie  seul dans une
pièce j'aimerais trouver un nouvel éclairage pour des
tableaux qu'on n'a pas encore vus
il y a quelque chose en moi je ne sais pas
ce que c'est ce que je vois personne d'autre ne le voit
il
y a un étranger ici tu bois trop
ta starid  devenir incontrôlable je ne veux pas
me calmer ça s'appelle l'acte de
peindre pour une raison tu ne vois pas que
ce tableau est désagréable
les habitants ont signé une pétition
contre toi ils ne veulent pas que tu
revienne je peux  ne restez pas ici Vincent est
entouré de stupides méchants ignorants
à mort la raison pour laquelle vous g  pas quelques-uns
ici aucune vision du monde c'est assez
effrayant n'est-ce pas
[Musique]
parfois je me sens si loin de
tout je pense que je perds la tête
parfois ils disent que je suis fou mais un grain
de folie c'est mieux  de notre
[Musique]
crois-tu que Dieu t'a donné le
don de me payer pour te garder dans la misère Je
n'y ai jamais pensé de cette façon
[Musique]
Je serais un imprimeur pour les gens qui ne sont pas
encore nés dis-moi frère
mon  bon peintre pas un bon peintre si je
voyais que tu es un grand peintre personne n'est
tellement à partager ce que je dis
maintenant je pense juste à ma relation
à l'Éternité
toi